dans nuit on dit souvent vous êtes un
bon vivant comme comme comme l'était
jacques chirac et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez été extrêmement
triste bien sûr de la disparition de
jacques chirac vous avez dit je me
déplace que pour lui ce soir je sais que
ces voix là c'est vous dites chaque
français à son jacques chirac évidemment
chacun d'entre nous à son jacques chirac
est ce que voulait dire par là parce
qu'il me fera beaucoup c'est que on est
tristes ou ampleur en corrèze ou à paris
en métropole en outre mer mais on pleure
aussi à jérusalem et à ramallah
on pleure aussi dans des villages de
chine et du japon ont peur je parle pas
des chefs d'état africains évidemment
très marqué mais dans les villages
d'afrique
que vous soyez tout 6 août ou non mme
bard a cessé et qu'est ce qui fait que
cet homme aujourd'hui cet homme qui
représente la france a un tel impact
nous on parle on parle de notre chirac
on aime on parle de la corona on parle
des blagues mais c'est bien plus que ça
le premier cherche et au monde qui dit
attention on est juste une humanité
c'est le discours de jo nesbo pas
seulement la maison brûle c'est la
phrase d'après sur l'humanité du 20e
siècle
je sais le chef d'état qui dit face à
l'armada face à un proche orient pour
koné si mal lui qui le connaît si bien
i stop c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait je
rappelle qu'à l'époque n'est pas une
décision si simple c'est l'homme qui au
vel d'hiv
mais relisons le discours du vel d'hiv
sur la reconnaissance dont la faute
c'est celle homme qui dénoue la crise de
2,70 de grenelle social avant avant les
autres vont elles faire qu'est-ce qui
fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on pleure dans
plein de vie
du monde pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut re
liban et on sait elle est en ce moment
pourquoi est-ce qu'on pleure en irak et
ancien en ce moment il ya donc ce
français et je voulais ma réponse magma
ma conviction ce n'est qu'à l'aube qui
en france moi il m'a juste moi je
n'étais que son ministre
je suis pas un ami j'suis pas j'étais
son petit exécutants mais dit jean-louis
la fracture sociale c'est la fracture de
notre république
fais moi un teint de plan de cohésion
sociale et de rénovation urbaine
le plus grand chantier civil de
l'histoire de france 46 milliards
c'était pour le quartier parce que nos
quartiers c'est le coeur de ne paie rien
sinon c'est le divorce
si l'on bat bref donc cet homme pour moi
il représente quelque part un petit bout
de nos humanités que tu sois en
casamance à côté d'addis abeba au liban
à jérusalem ramallah aujourd'hui il ya
un type qui à un moment donné effet le
discours du vel d'hiv et quand il à
jérusalem il voulait rentrer dans mon
pays si vous empêchez vous policiers
d'aller voir la rade de genève
donc si tout le monde s'y retrouve thé
chinois thé japonais tête casamance t1
10 points pour tout et des dom tom
[Applaudissements]
eh bien et puis je vais arrêter
j'entendais dans la bagnole des
commentateurs ouais ils étaient géniaux
crise et a nommé gère formidable tient
compte on est parti on est très aimé et
puis il était très sympathique alors le
bilan et la petite impasse que dedans
parce que ouais tu sais ces espèces
d'estaimpuis la petite musique c'est
clair mais bon decaux le bilan que je te
le donnerai on avait moins chaud matches
que les allemands aient moins de déficit
que les allemands on réduisait la fri il
réduisait la fracture sociale est en
crue construisait deux fois plus de
logements
parce que voilà à quoi là c'est c'est à
la fois l'humanité et en vraie terre
c'est un type je sais pas ce qu'ils
avaient sauf sa curieuse idée si elle ya
pas un individu vivant aujourd'hui
qu'ils puissent tout raconter
chacune des ethnies son voyage son
histoire pourquoi es tu dis ouf on sait
on voit pas en irak parce que lui
connaît il connaît le proche orient
il sait que c'est pas avec de l'armement
que tu parles de l'histoire des peuples
et leur géographie
voilà et c'est cet homme-là qui nous a
quittés et moi j'ai juste un truc si on
pouvait juste être comme et c'est
l'histoire tu as le sage te montre la
montagne et est le crétin regardera et
bien si on pouvait arrêter d'être éteint
ce serait pas mal
[Applaudissements]